is not here today
um because yesterday he made my legs
look fat when he was sitting on my lap
and that's just like a personal boundary
I will not allow for usually I never
watch our episodes but in Florida like
I've been really enjoying watching our
episodes once we're done with them
because I don't know it's like fun and
fresh and I could not get myself to
watch him yesterday my knees
looked
first of all I looked 87 with like my
wrinkling like it was all Theo's fault
we all know it's my fault I'm
scapegoating Theo no that is why I
switched it up today and I wore like a
tracksuit that way I don't have to worry
about my legs it's also so cold in here
our legs like turn purple and they're
just like really Grandma it's not cute
further notice like I will not be
showing my legs on this particular set